send your paper from a journal you see
them at all and they would only open it
after you asked them to to open it and
the reason was that you know it would be
like a time stamp it would register you
meet the your paper it said at time and
the thing is that as long as the paper
is not public you can see like a perfect
this was this was the system and then it
was cancelled after after it was
discovered the people misuse date and
and we have two papers with two
conflicting results and asked us to open
the right one and yeah so I guess I had
like a similar a a similar thing and I I
wasn't sure whether i should give a talk
about harness or talk about algorithms
so well i'm going to give to talk about
algorithms and it's a job work with with
my suit us in whose was an undergrad I
tie my teeth okay okay so I'll just
pretty okay so
um in other words so we to talk about
algorithms which you know is owed them
all just sanity checks on and okay so
the algorithm cell phone disconnects our
problem known as label cover or
projection gain so let me just start by
quickly introducing it and know so if
you ask Google what the projection game
is this is what you get this is not a
projection game for this talk so what we
have is a bipartite graph it has two
sides Part A and Part B and all the
edges of between a and B and a vertices
get assigned labels from an alphabet
find out that called Sigma a and
reverses I'll get assigned labels from
Sigma B these are labels and on the
edges we have constraints and each
constraint as you given the label to the
first endpoint what's what's the label
that's supposed to be on on the on the
endpoint or bomb if if the label on the
eight point and we're going to say that
an edge is a satisfied by an assignment
of labels to the vertices if the
projection actually holds if you look at
what the the a endpoint gets and the X
on the B endpoint it's exactly what the
beep endpoint yes and the commensal
problem is is given such an instance of
the graph and constraints and so on
final assignments that satisfy as many
as many edges as possible and we say
that an instance is fully satisfiable
satisfiable if all the edges can be
satisfied by non assignments and we'll
set a serious inspire boy if almost all
the edges can be satisfied so that's the
that's a problem
and let me give you two examples for
projection games the first example is
this dessert game and this sub game is
as follows the bee vs correspond to
boolean variables and a versus
correspond to constraints on the on the
herbals and say that each constraint is
a clause on the variables so each
constraint is going to be connected to
the D variables in it and an assignment
to the constraint is just an assignment
to each of the D variables in the
constraint and the assignment has to be
satisfying for the constraint and the
assignment to do the B vertex if paddy
ok so so so this is the ad game another
example is uni games or Pete one game
and I did here is that well you say that
the game is Pete one if if we know the
label to be vertex then the exactly be
possibilities on the label to the a
vertex fold all of the edges in the
graph these are fit 1 and del usually
considered is a little with P equals one
diesel evening games or with p1 games or
with P which is which is large so so
this is the second example and both
those examples come up a lot it
disappeared we're going to discuss that
and what what we're doing in this work
is showing combinatorial algorithms for
650 nearest satisfiable projection games
and all those algorithms really are
compete at oriole they're really there
is no right context following and stuff
and there is no reason is that the
scenarios the cases it will considering
a really one
wear contacts programming is not right
right tool so so it it's nicer for talk
about it or algorithms that they're all
easy to to explain so we shall three
algorithms and I'm going to talk about
two of them the first is a polynomial
time algorithm that gives ratio this
approximation of all projection games
we're going to discuss this this spread
oh let me say that that not purple
because you can always satisfy one edge
in a projection game right one edge is a
fraction one ovary fraction 1 over e
times Sigma is is much lower however
what saves the day that he'll do is this
oh this fourth food which which makes it
much better than than obvious algorithm
and still is it looks like a terrible
algorithm however it may be tied or even
old I don't know it's tight but also
tighten some in some way and we're going
to discuss that so so this is the first
algorithm that I'm going to talk about
the second algorithm which I'm not going
to talk about is the subjects financial
time algorithm which is exact for smooth
satisfiable projection games as
smoothness is such defines several years
ago um yeah
and the third algorithm which which I
will discuss is this pitiful in Owenton
Proclamation scheme for projection games
and unique games on click but so these
are these are the results and let me
tell you beat why we care about leopard
covering projection games what are the
parameters that we should fix so the
importance of level cover comes from
this theorem the strong PCP theorem and
it says that the labor cover is
extremely extremely hard proximate so
you can always epoxy me you can always
you know satisfy one edge turns out that
you can't really guarantee that you
satisfy much more on so this is the fear
and constancy sajid epsilon which is
placed pretty normally smoothly on the
older is a carry that depends on epsilon
and given a projection game of size n
well size is set aside of the graph of
the edges and the verses alphabet size K
even if you know that all the edges can
be satisfied simultaneously so right
away I somehow generated this game was
to have in mind some some satisfying
assignment and everything or the
constraint much that they'll consistent
with this satisfying even then it is NP
hard to find an assignment if you know
even if all i ask for it from it is is
free to sin phi epsilon fraction of the
so all the edges can be satisfied
but it's going to be computationally
hard to satisfy even a tiny fraction now
this is true oh so we proved it in two
thousand I performing but with k which
is exponential in in one of your exes oh
you mean nonprofit size can be 1
exponential as long as X 1 time in 1
over epsilon as long as it just depends
on epsilon this is a theorem yes there
is about that because absolutely this
point no really small and then if if at
that precise is exponentially in 1 by
epsilon things yes so so this theorem is
yes I'm going to talk about what's known
and what's not known and we're far from
actually proving the right theorem here
but but as is this is correct right you
could consider k which is you know sighs
exponentially in 1 over epsilon even
pull small epsilon and this is no it's
fine showing you wanna perhaps you know
this is a serum will heal its
exponentially in 1 over epsilon we would
really want it to be putting only in 1
over epsilon and we don't know how to
but Full Faith and I'm going to discuss
all those things but but the truth is
that it you know the point is that this
is an NP hard problem to satisfy even a
tiny fraction of the of the edges are
assuming that the alphabet side is large
enough and the reason that this is an
extremely important theorem is that most
optimal NP hardness of approximation
results of this um and let's see one
very known example hugs three soft you
get a fleece at instance and you have a
bunch of clauses over variables boolean
variables and each chose depends on
three boolean variables okay
and very famous a nice result of your
hand is that it's NP hard to approximate
within seven or eight epsilon fold any
constant epsilon and this epsilon here
is determined by the epsilon that come
from collection games this this hearon
works by sorry with some combining it
with with long codon and so on so you
know one of the motivations for this
work was you know let's let's understand
what's what's epsilon so we understand
what exactly about pooping will be seven
over a classic sound crime so so why is
this interesting right so I'm explicit
is very E is easy to satisfy seven over
eight fraction of the of the constraints
with random silence know that leaves
this special behavior it seven over
eight all right if we assume that fit
the sap exact site requires exponential
time this epsilon and epsilon prime they
tell us how how sharp the the threshold
is and it may look like you know why do
we really care if it's epsilon this
accidental that epsilon so you know one
is Islam you know it's nice to see if we
actually understand it but but really
this is a it's kind of an optical
illusion this is a small quantity so we
don't really care about it so full so
let me explain that moxley's are the
threshold is at seven over eight for
other programs the threshold is in other
places sometimes the threshold is is 0
for example when the
sighs very large van really the epsilon
is the important parameter still epson
looks like very small and why do we care
of this this small epsilon is awesome
other small epsilon well so because this
is a maximization problem we consider
approximations as well between 0 and 1
if which was a minimization problem we
would have considered one over that and
then this very small epsilon would have
become this huge 1 over epsilon and then
it becomes somehow easier to digest that
the difference between different epsilon
is actually very important very
different approximation okay so this is
one motivation for this work we want to
understand this epsilon this is going to
be the first algorithm that will see
other motivation so we want to
understand this scheme so so smooth
projection games or something that the
sebastian other is used in such hardness
of approximation results and then the
question is you know how good the skin
is how efficient it is can we get result
of this type using using these OG and
results about planar graphs you know
what what if multiplicities is you know
we care about cleaner instances which
which many people care about and these
are instances that come up in into it in
the real world and you know is this
scheme good enough to argue about about
10 or instances so so that's the
motivation for this work any questions
before we actually start
okay so let me leave you the what's
known about the connection between the
size of the of the input and and the
alphabet and and epsilon because also
Sebastian and David so let's start with
the hardest results you know in strong
PCP theater and what what parameters do
we get so long pulled the palpitation
theorem and what it shows is that
projection games are np-hard even if K
is pretty small is polynomially in 1
over epsilon well as long as epsilon is
is constant and and we would want it for
even some constant epsilon so in this
sense is be unsatisfactory then with
line would put a in comfortable result
but but in some sense better is all oh
the fourth for any epsilon but give eyes
of the number of labels with exponential
including 10 trips then usually we we
want k to be at most polynomial and then
cases most polynomial if epsilon is at
most some algorithm in 1 over some log
and some power but but it did work for
sub constant epsilon and in this sense
it was better recently talked about
David and innate showed that you don't
really need this polynomial here you
actually get
one over epsilon with you pay some price
overhead of the reduction um and then
the conjecture which I call the
projection games conjecture with the
hope that they will sound attractive to
all approximation algorithms people and
then start proving results assuming so
the hope is that we'll be able to pull
this okay which is just putting on this
problem is np-hard and and okay so so so
these are the hardest results what do we
know about the don't we know about
algorithms so we know that epsilon is at
least 1 over N + 1 over K 1 over the
size one of the number of edges and one
over the alphabet size this is just this
just says that we can always buy one
edge and this says always satisfy one
over the size of the alphabet this just
works by guessing an assignment it's
expected to satisfy these fractions so
this explains why k is at least one of
our EPS alone in odense it's all we
would like for this is one of that song
yup so their projection games conjecture
is really a strengthening the beach
yellow conductor right yes yes so
so there was a projector 20 years ago
which became known as the same scale
conjecture not like God goes faster than
that Russell and the conjecture was that
you would have to worries and he we say
that vital why put in a really small
because of epsilon it will remain
polynomial so so they just stated that
and I think with the year is it became
clear that may be the actual result we
want is such a result for projection
games because this is what we'd like
reducing fun so yeah I don't know if
it's going to work for me to give it a
name so people you remember that but
this is this was the hope and okay so so
this is for / we can always satisfy this
fraction of edges this is easy
approximation then some approximation
algorithms people started working on it
one of the patient of Peleg was that you
can combine the two one somewhat weaker
station you can get one over spot an x k
and then there was a work by mother's
charcoal Higgy guy and cut off and they
managed to infer the two half here to
one-third and then in the first result
of this paper what we do is is that 21 /
4 I should say that the day actually
work in a bit more general setting we
just care about satisfiable projection
games they consider general to query
games service it is possible but we
focus on on the statistical projection
games because this is just a more the
case that people usually consider so
that's that's the first result so i want
to show you this result but before I do
that let me just mention that this photo
station we're going to make one
simplifying assumption and the
simplifying assumption is the de Graaf
that we consider is by regular and it's
pete one possibly for a very large p we
don't just work for but it's pit one
that is all the edges have the same each
label has the same number of free images
and then everything is nice and
symmetric and we don't have to care
about all kinds of I symmetries that a
kind of annoying okay so let me tell you
about this this algorithm and all that
approach of this algorithm is this a
win-win approach we are going to show
for combinatorial algorithms and each
community our algorithm is is going to
give something and going to have some
advantage in some case and then if we
have all those for full every graph you
know we can always do the best out of
the four and what we're going to all
here is the best out of the four is is
pretty so here the performances of the
of the algorithms we show the first
algorithm is going to satisfy one over
DB fraction will deviate the degree of
the B vertices on the second algorithm
is going to satisfy p over sigma to the
a fraction will what the game spit one
game so peas and level 3 images of each
label the third algorithm is going to
satisfy age x da over
EP action pieces before age is the
larger now in the largest number of
neighbors of neighbors of an a vertex
how to train but we've talked about that
and and the fourth algorithm satisfies
DB over the age a a function of the
edges okay so Somali why those numbers
those parameter is actually actually
better because of the following the folk
summation factor is the maxim of all
those four and the maximum for the four
well is at least as large as the
geometric mean of the certification for
foods of the multiplication then if you
take all those four approximation ratios
and you multiply them and it take for
food this is what you get so right so
the DB here cancels with a DB here and
be a here cancels with yay you're the
age in the age and the P&P this is all
you have so this is what this is what
we're going to do and to make it a bit
more painting mmm so I'd actually ask
you what the algorithms are and we'll
see whether whether you can write the
paper for us okay so suppose I want you
to get one over TV approximation what do
you do
yeah so right this is this poster I can
only please one person a day and so so
the idea is that the you know think of a
bit vertex B vertex has d/b/a vertices
that want something that project
something to eat the problem here is to
satisfy all of them if you only try to
satisfy one right this is free this is
pretty easy just you know choose
arbitrarily assignments with a and just
satisfy one okay so so this is the okay
so this is easy and now what if i want
to satisfy p over sigma to the a sigma a
edges of function of the edges peas is
the number of pre images of each be
label what do you do here
yeah yeah so just you just randomize so
you pick an assignment at random and and
the idea is that you don't full each for
it take an edge look at the assignment
to the B vertex the P good assignments
to the a vertex now you just picked one
out of Sigma a at random they'll feed it
a good one so you get P oversee hey this
is also easy now it's good now it gets a
bit more tricky how do you get an age x
da over PE observation age is the number
of neighbors of neighbors of an Avery
maximal some this is this is H so na is
the number so let's let's denote an a by
the set of a neighbors and an end to a
is the neighbors of the neighbors of a
okay the second order neighborhood and I
want and age is going to be the largest
of these overall a the largest second
level of the faith so the idea here is
this take your little a vertex and you
can go over all the assignments tool to
a this is something you do first time
into a you can see what it projects on
the B vertices here you know now you
have you have the assignments to all the
big vertices now for each a neighbor
they'll just P possibilities that's the
definition of be
so one of those p is good and you can
always satisfy an assignment you can
always satisfy all of the edges one of
one of the say differently so we know
that this projection game is is fully
satisfied okay there is an assignment
that satisfies everything ok so one of
the of the assignments here is of the
right assignment and it projects the
right assignment here and one of the P
possibilities for each of the vertices
is the right is the right one and this
satisfies all of the edges that touch it
so it must be an assignment that
satisfies that many edges and you can
just you can just find it ok that's the
third algorithm and then the fourth
algorithm says it you can always that's
the kind of the trade-off so this was
this worked well if the second
neighborhood was big what if the second
neighborhood this is always it's always
small so if the second-ever what is
always small then that's also a pretty
good algorithm that there is also a
pretty good algorithm because what you
can do because this basically means that
the graph is very clustered with the
second neighborhood they stay inside so
what you can do is do this divide and
conquer algorithm you can take the
second neighborhood just care about that
it's very connected to the rest of the
graph so just you know give up all those
edges that it's connected to and and
just repeat
so so this is the fourth algorithm take
this egg that has a second level which
is very small find the good an
assignment plate that's that's easy like
we did before and just just disconnect
that and continue and you can continue
the claim is you can continue this many
times and still satisfy many new edges
so that's the fourth algorithm and all
of those fall together one of those fall
together give you what you want so
that's the that's the first result of
this paper any questions about this
evaporator okay so let me tell you about
the third result of this algorithm which
is a pitiful planar graphs if the
projection graph is this planar then
it's easy um okay so what what this
algorithm uses is a well-known framework
in community optimization for hitting
with with thinner graphs which is um the
idea is the following double they're
going to be two two steps library from
the first the first step is going to be
we're going to delete the few of the
edges it's not fracturing the edges and
we're going to ensure that the graph has
constant free with what's true with I'm
going to explain the next time and on
graphs with constant free with then it
is a very easy dynamic firming algorithm
so that's the that's approach okay so
let me tell you about about trees
in 3 width so a treat the decomposition
of the graph is as follows you have a
set of vertices and you have a tree
structure on the on the set ok so now
those those subtle vertices elude not
disjoint they have variables in common
and we're going to see what what
constraint that said they satisfy the
first constraint is that for every edge
there is some I such that the edge is
completely contained in this VI so say
if I have an edge you've even here well
it's contained and the second poverty is
it if I have a vertex which is both here
and here say V is both healing here then
it's also on every on every set in the
tree so that's that's a poverty the
poverties of the tree decomposition not
only is it that the trivial treated the
decomposition is just have all the
vertices in one set right and then
everything is fine but the tree width of
the composition is the maximum size of
of a set minus minus 1 right so what we
are trying to do is to put only very few
are verses together ok so that's that's
a problem
and the serum of time that's what going
to use is that if you take player graph
then you can always remove very not very
small fraction of the edges for every
care you can move most one over K
fraction of the edges and you get in
free width which is just ordered so you
can open garage you can always have such
a decomposition where each one then just
contains now why why is this useful
because we can do we can now do the
following we can scan this tree from the
bottom up on the leaves are then so and
all the so after we did you know with a
movie I just now all the edges of inside
some be ice okay so if we we scan what's
inside clusters and we also cannot be
all the edges but within each within
each set within each cluster we only
have a constant number of vertices which
means that we can actually go over all
possible assignments inside and we can
remember for we can we can write down
from each of the assignments here how
many edges it satisfies and what we can
do is you know if we stand bottom-up we
can remember for each one not just how
many edges inside satisfies but how many
edges it satisfies in the sub tree and
we can just go up until we find the good
assigning
so that's that's the second algorithm I
wanted to discuss any questions about
this yes yes yes so the theorem said you
can do it in linear time Oh for planar
graphs not for general graphs yeah yes
does this extent to excavate my nerve it
extends whenever you know you can get
concentrate with you can get that about
many asses of graphical truth ok so just
to summarize we saw two algorithms out
of the three in the paper and the first
algorithm gave this very miserable
approximation factor however however it
may be titled close to type in
particular if we believe the this
projection games conjecture and most
people seem to to believe that then you
know there should be some constant here
such that this would be optimal so it's
interesting whether this constant is 1
over 400 something else and sometimes
people see this is this a lecture and
they think ok so you know you gave full
algorithms maybe there is a fifth
algorithm six algorithm and so on maybe
you can get other you know not one over
four but one of the five or six or seven
but but then if you can get something
better than that then it would potential
game changer so so that's very
interesting
and the second algorithm that we saw was
the speakers for projection and uni
games on on paragraphs and you can see
that is another discontinuation for this
line of research that tries to get
algorithms home phone community games on
all kinds of easy structures this is
another is a structure following against
an example general culture ok so that's
it talk and any questions we mentioned
the crap he mentioned the reserve and
sub exponential time out yeah so but it
depends on this smoothness parmiter so
it's not very no but what is the
difference it's kind of the obviously
and it's good like this it go Lucy to
lend the epsilon to the one man it's
it's not present it is sort of what the
kind of the obvious thing that you would
do it there is no I I don't remember bye
thank you yes I don't remember line III
they fell to bad-mouth my boy work I
don't know but but it's interesting that
it so there is no linear degradation to
gets me through exhibitions
yes and but this is sort of not but we
will kind of falling short from actually
giving a very strong sub exponent
algorithm the dependence in the
smoothness is sort of not good enough to
to give a very easy this satisfying
explanation all that but yes my belief
is that maybe there is an expensive
wines projection beams and experience
the night so there is a Russian
projection games to the closest vector
problem on lattices yes this is true
that you will get into the upsilon
hardness wizard for lattices and their
hardness of the polynomial factors for
lattice problems that kind of consider
in some sense the Holy Grail because
there are cryptosystems with North art
and such things and they're actually for
the largest problems at sqrt n factor in
fact becomes in and printer set point B
so it cannot even be at the heart so
there I think is really interesting
whether it's into the 144 million to the
one-third whatever
how does the constant behaving badly
repetition diversity
NP hardness can you suppose you've moved
production next one over into one for
you
value addition so right so this is a
question for David Wright because the
usual palpitation just doesn't work for
lower because right you have to think
about you to see it was really salad
with point 99 and right and then then
there is the feeling of davidon animated
that can actually work no error yeah so
good for any substance then if you get
really sick with you it with that's
right so the question is a hoe exactly
close the gap so what's exactly the
constant you get how much it goes versus
how my dead Fox emission factor it's all
alike get one or illiterate because of
the size of the game and alphabet gross
right both of the other the size goes in
the right way in her petition yeah yeah
okay this is my story like that came to
the possibility of losing some factors
other questions comments are those
speculations thanks again
textbook at three